rhodium is a metal which is used very
widely in catalysts it is particularly
important in chemical reactions such as
the one that makes ethanoic acid that is
one of the components of vinegar but
it's made industrially from carbon
monoxide and methanol and the key
component to make this reaction work a
rhodium compound but like many of the
elements in this part of the periodic
table rhodium is a very rare metal it's
not widely found in in nature and
therefore it's really quite expensive
and I have been to catalyst manufacturer
and been shown a large VAT which they
said has half a million pounds worth of
rhodium compound in and when you
actually look in there's a remarkably
small pile of material at the bottom